thank you so much christian high
cholesterol increases your risk of
illness so we spoke to southwest medical
the sponsors of this next segment to
learn more on how to prevent it and stay
healthy
dr orr welcome to las vegas now
thank you thank you for having me
absolutely we are talking cholesterol
awareness so let's just get to the
basics of what cholesterol is and how it
affects the body
well first of all it's really important
to to get your cholesterol checked uh to
maintain a healthy lifestyle um it is
well known that uh cholesterol high
cholesterol is uh increased risk for
developing heart disease which can lead
to heart attacks and strokes um
and which is one of the leading causes
of death in the u.s so it's important to
know what your cholesterol is you can
control
the risk factors for developing heart
disease and just a little bit about
cholesterol it's actually a fatty
substance made in the liver
that is an essential part of having good
normal health
really vital in
development of hormones in your body as
well as digesting fatty foods
and another important point is their
cholesterol our body makes all the
cholesterol that we actually need
so most experts actually recommend that
we limit the amount of dietary
cholesterol intake which includes foods
such as red meat
poultry seafood
and the common one we think of as eggs
and dairy products
okay good to know and what are some of
those risk factors that we need to look
out for
well some of the primary risk factors
are
family history so hereditary component
so
some individuals may be predisposed
based on their
genetics
also lifestyle and activity so exercise
plays a big part in controlling your
cholesterol and then predisposing
medical conditions such as cholesterol
so your doctor may recommend that you
get your cholesterol checked more often
if you have those risk factors like
diabetes or if you're overweight
or
if you're older
in terms of age
so those risk factors are important to
look at and have your doctor follow
okay and how do you maintain a healthy
cholesterol level
yeah there's about four major things you
can do one is diet so maintaining a
healthy diet avoiding
saturated fats trans fats
high carbohydrate diet and a high salt
intake it's important to maintain a high
fiber diet focusing on
vegetables and fruits
as well as unsaturated fats such as
avocado or nuts
okay and really quickly here what are
statins and
what do they accomplish
well statins are a really important
medication and that um
they help to kind of block the enzyme
that's responsible for producing more
cholesterol in your body
many studies have been done that show
that the statins are safe and effective
so there's quite a bit of talk about
statins and the concern over uh the risk
of side effects which are no different
than many other medications that are out
there
um however the benefit is is incredible
and that it helps to significantly
reduce your risk for cardiovascular
disease so something really important
thing to talk with your doctor about
whether or not you are at high risk for
having
heart disease related to high
cholesterol and whether there's a need
for starting a statin therapy
thank you southwest medical associates
for sponsoring this segment they have
locations across southern nevada for
more information call
702-877-5199 or just visit smalv.com
mercedes